on this episode I talk men and women
fertile grounds and wine everybody this
is gary vay-ner-chuk and you're watching
the askgaryvee show episode 20 fun fact
about the number 20 I never thought we'd
get to number 20
Stephen asks as a man I find it
extremely difficult to accept that other
men use Pinterest anyway I can overcome
this bias Stephen there's a way you can
overcome this bias it's called stop
being a dick that's all I've got for you
man you know I'm not trying to razz
probably trying to get a little time to
talk about the truths pecos 2012
Grenache abut there's not much to go
into it I mean I you know I get it but
if you're a man that is trying to market
or sell or story tell or create
awareness to women women are spending
obnoxious amounts of time on this
platform at scale a major leader and so
if you're targeting fifteen-year-old
guys the 19 year old guys to sell them
sports equipment you don't need
Pinterest but if you want the audience
that lives there well then you need to
play there and your [ __ ] bias is
surely not helping you
Esmond asks how do you get around
letting a business run their new social
media plan by themselves has been we
were debating this question a little bit
I want to make sure I've got it right
you know what you Steve real quick let's
Steve go deeper into chucks rowdy rowdy
has never been on the show well yeah I
mean like just tell you know like let's
you don't want to go a little behind the
scenes here because I want to make sure
s I don't want has been tweeting like
Gary B you got my question wrong I want
to make sure you take the blame okay so
here's what I thought you're asking if
you are a client services company and
you're teaching your clients how to be
better with social and developing
strategy for them how do you prevent
them from just taking the IP that you've
given them and running off and and doing
their own thing with it yeah they make
sense on the slippy sniff I get a little
black raspberry clearly some pepper
there's a lot of huge fruit there's
almost like sugar exploding up with the
raspberries you know obviously a lot of
you who've watched while every team in
the past know these kind of wines scare
me because there's a little oak it might
be overblown 92 points Tanzer 92 points
Robert Parker average play 16 bones I'm
gonna use average price that askgaryvee
since this isn't while every team in I
wanna give wine libraries price but
average price across the country is 16
bucks but an interesting those fruity
would be very popular with the kids
you guys like fruit cool say fruit
people like the fruit anyway back to the
question there's a very simple easy way
my friend when I started vaynermedia
everybody kept asking me this how do
your IP they take it they run it no no
no no no this is a continuous game I
know everything about snapchat stories
right now I know deeply that binds
thinking about different things I know
what's evolving in Facebook the best way
to keep clients from not running away
from you after they get something out of
you is to still have something to give
you Kerry V it's leave alone here from
you got this bro first of all on behalf
of myself and all the motivators here
you've got this bro thank you so much
what were your teachings all your books
all your videos you are the man has no
doubt about it love your stuff man my
question is really simple we speak a lot
in schools colleges universities we have
messages that we want to give out we
want to help teach these kids bring them
to a better place help them become a
better version of themselves but the
problem is is for all the following that
we've build up from all the people on
Twitter and Instagram and YouTube and
stuff like that a lot of the schools
don't really care about that stuff so my
question is how do I convey what
following is to people in schools head
teachers lecturers professors how do I
convey that to someone who just doesn't
care about that stuff
thanks man will really appreciate you
help please peace don't add any of that
let the whole thing run um I love this
question
I spend no time convincing people to
believe in what I believe in
I've been coming wines the Internet
itself back in 97 Google AdWords in 2000
emails in 97 social today snapchat two
years ago
I have no virtue Allah al 'ti oculus
rift in a couple years I have no
interest in convincing anybody about
myself so mate here's the mistake you're
making that so many make they're wasting
good time and energy trying to convince
while taking that same time and
allocating it to reaching more people
you need to reach out to every single
School professor and organization in the
world or your region or where you want
to play all of them find the 18 that are
intrigued and spend your time there
versus one by one spending a week a
month a year trying to convince this
person and then nothing happens don't
try to convert the unconverted ball I'm
thrilled that they don't get it make fun
of them after you're done in a couple
years and say me remember when you
didn't get it you're an idiot that's fun
I love doing that and that's what you
need to do so take all your time because
that's the asset for all of you
listening here and noticed them notice
in the comment section I'm trying to get
the answers that helps anybody no matter
what they do even though these are
specific questions that is the talent I
have as a storyteller this is a big one
take the time that you have that is the
asset it's the only one there's not more
of it's the big one and apply it to
places where there's fertile grounds go
reach out to more grounds to find out
which ones are fertile versus trying to
convert a non fertile one into a fertile
one Eduardo asks as the frontman of
vaynermedia your clients must expect to
meet you how do you manage that that's
an easy one to manage you know very
honestly this is a huge misconception
this company is called vaynermedia yes
I'm the front man but I do not convey
that they are buying me to anyone and
when we get into new business rowdy you
do a lot of new business short rowdy
Trouty how often do you find that people
think they're buying me less and less
these days and and what happens when you
think that happens well it or when it
happens what do we do
we convince them that there are a lot of
smart people while I'm here by showing
the great work very PR of you I mean the
the very simple fact is I'm not selling
me we let people know upfront that
there's no buying me and me look the
Million Dollar Man and WWF was right
everybody's got a price you can buy me
it's just a lot more than you think
and so we invent a company something
scalable I have no interest in being in
every room I'm running the business
there I jump into things bat phone all
day all the time because it's our
company and I'm part of it but you're
not buying me so we just convinced them
by telling them the truth Heather asks
Gary I've watched every a so but guys
outnumber women do you see women and men
differ on success and tactics Heather a
great point someone we need more women
questions but you can only do what you
can I mean the truth is you know now
they're losing some weight maybe we'll
get some more female fans but that the
fact that matter is I really think that
I need more female pants no I think I
think that um I think that there's
absolutely no it's crazy and so funny
how I think about business I don't care
if you're a corkscrew if you've got the
guts if you've got the juice if you've
got the ability I'm super interested I
don't I don't see you know we're
probably a 60/40 female company and
we're probably more crowding what are we
63
so we're 63% female driven company and
on the upper scour executive creative
director the woman that runs our San
Francisco office up until last week are
literally my right hand managing
director I mean I don't see any real
difference up one I'm not looking for
any real difference but I don't see a
huge difference of how you know a male
or a female view successor or acting I
mean within them their differences right
I mean I don't think that I don't yet
you look nobody's confused that we're
wider differently but I haven't really
noticed it but what I have noticed is
that this wines finish is continuous on
the palate I'm pretty surprised how long
it is and overall it's a pretty juicy
wine
I'm a little bit back not back when I
was doing while every TV when it comes
to fruit bombs and a lot of fruit I was
probably a three out of ten enthusiasts
towards the tip en got into daily grape
I was probably at four point five so I
started growing I'm probably in that
same four point five vein right now but
as you saw earlier people love the fruit
and this is wine a lot of people are
gonna love
I think Tanzer and Parker so I haven't
debated with Tamsin Parker in a long
time
I think kids are part of our being a
little bit generous with ninety two
point scores to me this is more of an 89
plus but for a barbecue wine football
seasons here and a tailgate this is one
juicy effing wine I don't want to curse
it's funny when I'm in a wine library
zone I don't want it's so near the brain
is crazy guys the brain is crazy
to me this is a great wine and it's
nationally distributed you should be
able to find it any night + GV score on
this little bad boy good fruit good
pepper good balance just a little too
fake juicy almost like too much makeup
you know and I don't like that like the
question of the day what is your
favorite food to bring to a tailgate and
and I appreciate yesterday because I'm
getting so much feedback it's helping
the show continue to give me feedback
lurkers thank you so much for coming out
yesterday I'll take more of you I
appreciate all of you you keep asking
questions I'll keep trying to answer
them